Ich bin Armin.
Ich bin Militärpolizist und Militärstreifensoldat.
Als Militärpolizist bezeichnen wir uns im Ausland und als Militärstreifensoldat bezeichnet man uns im Inland.
Im Ausland übernehmen wir auch durchgehend polizeiliche Aufgaben
und im Inland sind wir sozusagen die Polizei für das Bundesheer.
Eines unserer Hauptaugenmerke im Ausland ist speziell Zugriff,
das trainieren wir auch oft.
Ich bin Militärstreifensoldatin bei der ersten Kompanie Militärstreife&MP in Wien.
Genauso wie Ordnungsdsdienst, Sicherheitsdienst und dergleichen
sind auch Lotsungen ein großer Teil unseres Aufgabengebietes und gehören zum täglichen Brot.
Bei Lotsungen geht es hauptsächlich darum, dass das überschwere oder überlange Transportsystem
sich möglichst ungehindert im Verkehr bewegen kann
und dass alle anderen Verkehrsteilnehmer nicht gefährdet oder gestört werden.
Ich bin Mitglied vom Spezialverband Militärstreife und Militärpolizei und bin dort im Personenschutzteam.
Bei uns unterscheidet man zwei Übungsphasen.
Die eine Übungsphase ist zb. hier in der
Maria-Theresien-Kaserne.
Wir üben zb. das richtige Aus- und Einsteigen, das Gehen in der Formation mit der Schutzperson,
sowie das Evakuieren der Schutzperson in ein Fahrzeug.
Die anderen Phasen sind draußen in der Stadt,
dort wo wir direkt unter den Menschen arbeiten müssen